how many years you've been doing the
late night show it will be
19 years in january do you think by
giving you the summer off do you think
you'll stay at it longer or is it like
so nice having the summer off that you
start to go [ __ ] i don't even want to go
back where are you at with this yeah
i you know i vacillate i um
i do love having i love being off i love
not working it's really so much better
than working and the ideal situation is
having people doing my job for me while
i continue to get paid that's really the
right
but um
i don't know i don't know i i you know i
i think i know sometimes and then when
it comes time to make the decision
that i feel like i don't know but um
we'll see when i have to make that
decision
i will make that decision yeah do you
watch when let's say spade fills in or
nikki fills in do you watch them to see
if they're ruining your show or
enhancing your show or do you just say
[ __ ] it man i'm on vacation i cannot
worry about this i will watch i'll watch
and uh especially if i know know the
person i make a point to watch but i
don't get worked up about it in any way
and think like oh you should have done
this or
nor do i i won't send any kind of notes
or anything to my staff i just let them
figure it out my hope is that
after having guest host guest host over
the summer they will
they will come up with ways to make my
life easier when i get back because
there's a lot of stuff that i do that i
probably don't need to i think it takes
a secure man to have guest hosts but for
for example i was off for the summer i
had medicated pete filling for me look
how secure i was
but don't you have you ever been to a
therapist or psychiatrist because you
know i'd go
and you try to figure out as a performer
there must be a tremendous desire to
have an audience and to have people
looking at you and laughing and this and
that if you really walked away don't you
think there'd be some hole there in some
way not having your audience
i don't i don't really have that
honestly i never i you know people do
think i like i intended like my dream
was to host a late night talk show it's
just not true i mean if i'd been
a writer on david letterman's show i
would have been thrilled i would have
been very excited by that that would
have been more than enough for me and i
don't really have that um
that like i won't i'm not gonna go do
stand-up after
right i stopped doing the show um you
know maybe i'll i just need a little bit
you know i just need a little bit of
that i think i could get enough of it
from
social media i think i could be
perfectly happy making a a funny
30-second long video in my house and
posting it on instagram and going oh
that got a lot of likes i think that
would be enough for me